well you know struggle to visually or
more than bid him to remake society in
10 years when in 20 years we were going
to be carried off in chariots I well I'm
not sure maybe I mean I'm not sure maybe
the whole idea the eschaton might be one
of those ideas working militantly most
strongly against any social change
that's just hang on drive flying carpets
well they may be right so in that if
that were true would you think it a good
thing or a bad thing
well just in case the Eska term doesn't
snatch us from the fire yeah that's what
I have what to do at the end of time
this post-punk is a couple
yes I think we need to think of a
trigger would you call a clarion call in
your book and you know we want to avoid
the use of the word revolution due to
the fact that that always polarizes a
equal and opposite reaction which we
don't want to trigger but call it an
evolution and evolution in the past you
there have been all of these you know
popular uprisings were actually the
trigger okay we don't care who's elected
really on the 2nd of November for
president in the United States because
the government follows it doesn't lead
we need leadership now leadership comes
from people that's us so we don't want a
violent revolution and destroying all
these buildings downtown well somehow we
would like to see within seven years a
kind of a wake up where a certain number
of people just woke up and said that's
enough of that that's all what we the
idea and then to start doing it wet we
don't even know whatever triggered one
of these major social transformations of
the past such as let's say the
Renaissance or one we actually lived
through the 1960s
what triggered it I know what you'd say
it's too obvious that's what anyone
would say
[Music]